joining us right now let's again the
backdrop of the NCAA tournament that's
about to get its brackets in all of our
hands on Sunday from the worldwide
leader in sports one of the best in the
business one of my favorite people to
talk to Jay Bilas how are you Jay I'm
doing great rich how you doing I'm doing
fine what do you what is your thoughts
on the subject about clearly what the
Ivy League executive director Robin
Harris did and now schools are
apparently taking into their own hands
about decisions on whether to hold games
with fans or not at all what are your
thoughts here Jake well I glean uh I
went to I went to law school with Robin
so so I know her she's fantastic
and you know she's representing all the
presidents who came to that joint
decision about the you know the Ivy
League tournament and they're only four
teams in the Ivy League tournament but
it's on campus at Harvard this year so I
know how painful a decision that was for
everybody involved to sort of cancel
that competition but you know we're
seeing schools all over the country now
that are essentially canceling their
classes and telling their students don't
come back from Spring Break I know Duke
where I went to school has told students
not to come back and so at least April
the 20th and and that that's happened
with at least three Ivy League schools I
think you're mentioning Rutgers now is
taking some some steps so it's going on
all over the country and really this is
this is a health care issue and it's a
it's a public health issue so trying to
flatten the curve of this coronavirus so
that it doesn't overwhelm the health
care system and and so it seems
inevitable that it's going to reach the
n-c-double-a tournament and it's not
just the men's tournament like the
women's tournament is being played they
are going to be played at the same time
and the women's tournament is played on
campus sites to begin so Stanford's
already said they're only they're
allowing limited spectators at events
and and certainly that's going to have
to affect the women's tournament and the
optics of it for the NCAA's so can they
do what what did they do they can't you
know it's almost like they can't let
everyone else you know take these
measures and then all of a sudden but
yeah 75,000 people come in and watch us
that
that's gonna look a little off well I
mean again you're you're a basketball
analyst with a remarkable legal
background as we heard from from you
many times so you're not an expert on
public health and I don't mean to put
you in the position of being one that
said do you know what the machinations
or the decision-making process with the
NCAA would be to make a decision so
monumental with the first four happening
in a state where the governor said don't
do it or they're asking they're not
demanding and then there's a first round
series I think in both men and women in
the state of Ohio as well first in
second round do you know what the
decision-making process is actually
behind the scenes on this front Jay well
they have a they have a panel that
they've put together to give them advice
it was in the health care health
professional field and they're in
contact with the CDC and other
organizations to give them advice the
statement that the incidentally put out
and again there's a difference between
in this regard between the n-c-double-a
office and Indianapolis Mark Emmert and
all his employees and the conference's
so like I'm at the ACC tournament right
now the incident play has no say over
how the ACC runs its tournament if the
ACC decides to allow spectators not
allow spectators that's not Mark Emmert
skal the n-c-double-a tournament is his
call and and so as to how that
tournament is conducted that that's
going to be the call of the of the
office in Indianapolis with input from
the membership obviously but they've got
a panel of health care experts and then
they've got their own healthcare ask for
experts that are employed by the
n-c-double-a and the statement they put
out yesterday that mark ever put out
yesterday and yes subway suggested that
no one has told them that they cannot
have competition that they have not been
advised that they cannot hold
competition that that's that obviously
doesn't speak to whether they should
whether it's prudent to do so but
they've I think they're they're going to
handle this
well I'm optimistic that they're smart
enough and they have the advice and and
they're going to take all
appropriate steps like this is different
from should they pay the players or all
this other stuff and and their policies
in other areas which I think are I do
not trust them with this I do trust them
with I don't think they're going to make
any any public health decision that's
not going to be in the best interest of
everyone involved and it's not going to
be made with deliberate speed and and be
Prudential so I trust them to do that in
the long run though rich with the way
this is trending the next step would be
limited access of fans and because you
know it seems with the way everything's
going with with different companies that
I've been aware of and different
different governments and all that that
that having you know having these events
unless something changes it seems to be
trending toward the next step being
limited access of fans that we don't
want to have that many people in one
place that are coming that that are
likely to go back to to widespread areas
it seems like they're trending away from
that sort of thing for the time being
Jay Bilas from ESPN here on the Rich
Eisen show all right so now that we've
we've discussed that I guess let's get
to the matter at hand and how you think
the seeding is going to go at the very
top once we get these brackets in our
hands on Sundays we're sitting here on
Wednesday Jay Kansas and Gonzaga are
clear number ones I think Baylor is is
up there and if they get to the final is
big 12 they will stay there and then I
think Dayton has jumped San Diego State
the only I think the only things that
could change would be based upon if
Florida State were to rip through and
and when the ACC maybe they could jump
up there Duke would be a possibility but
and then Michigan State I think if they
were to win they could do that but you
know outside of the top seeds as they
stand now in all these different
bracketology that you see I don't see a
whole lot of teams jumping up there
there has been outside of you know like
I mentioned Kansas which
has lost three times and have only lost
the high level opponents did zag has
only lost a couple of times Baylor's
only lost four Dayton I think will grab
a number one seed if they win the a-10
tournament they've only lost twice and
they lost to Kansas and Colorado both of
those in overtime everybody else has has
a lot more losses and a lot more
blemishes and it's hard it's hard to see
a bunch of teams with the opportunity to
leapfrog those that are already there
well obviously Dayton's the one with a
if you can have a team that's won 29 of
30 one wearing a glass slipper they'd
have to be that one or obviously San
Diego State at 30 and to do they have
the the ability do you think to cut down
the nets when it's all done like take it
all down when it's said and done J I
think I think I think Dayton does and I
think both of them are final four
capable the obviously the the team's
ability to get to the Final Four there's
a lot wider swath the teams that can
navigate four games in a bracket where
somebody falls down in front of them
something like that winning six is a lot
different and I think there are only
eight maybe nine teams that I favor to
do that it doesn't mean it's impossible
that you can't see somebody like Butler
break through and do it like they almost
did in 2010 but it's a lot it's a lot
bigger task but both of them and
especially Dayton I think because dates
got they got a national player year
Canada I think he's going to be National
Player of the Year he'll be top and he's
a he's a lottery pick but they've also
got older players and they've got
they've got everything I think you need
the only issue that you would have is to
say well geez they haven't written like
who they beat like the best team they've
beaten or the highest ranked team is
probably st. Mary's
you know they beat Georgia but George is
not that great they beat Virginia Tech
Virginia Tech not that great they're
their best win was probably their loss
against Kansas that was their best
performance they were magnificent in
that game they lost in overtime to
Kansas and Maui which is one of the five
best games I think that it that was
played this year as far as level of play
and and those are the two heavyweight
taking a swing at one another but but
they're legit they're very very good but
you know how it is rich if they lose in
the sweet 16 right
you know people dismiss them and say I
told you they weren't that good stuff
like who's on the bubble for you Jay who
needs to have a big conference
tournament week in order to get in there
a bunch of them I think Stanford has to
win Indiana Indiana has to win
I think Providence is is going to make
it into the field because of how they
finished up but I would go losing in the
Big East tournament if I were them you
know I think teams like Cincinnati
Richmond those those teams have to win
but outside of that I think it's it's I
don't want to say it's fairly clear but
there's not a lot of wiggle room for
four teams to break through you know
it's sort of break through there a
couple that can fall out but there's a
there's probably eight teams that are
competing and and they've got you know
really spotty resumes I mean to the
point of being average teams and you
know I think one of the things that's
kind of interesting about this is you
know there are when you when you look at
at this event like this is the whole
championship event and man when people
say it's not fair to the little guy I
always kind of push back on that and say
hey look it may be more difficult for
the little guy but it's ridiculously
fair and because the little guy gets to
get to win their conference tournament
get in and then they have the
opportunity to get in as that large and
and without playing is tough a schedule
so I think it's really fair all right
score let me just walk in through the
front door what about my alma mater Jay
did this Michigan and Juwan Howard have
to come up with the the WS plural in the
Big Ten tournament in order to make it
what do you think I don't think so I
think I mean I wouldn't I wouldn't
recommend to anybody losing but I think
Michigan's gonna make it in because the
quality of when they have the fact that
Isaiah livers was out for so long but
that gives them a little bit of wiggle
room there at least some some argument
that hey wait a minute we didn't have
our best player for this this length of
time and when he went out we were being
touted as a top five team and they
actually were ranked I think fourth when
he went out with him healthy and their
whole team healthy
they're their top 25 good so I can't
imagine a scenario absent you know
looking horrible in the big 10
tournament where where they don't make
it and what about the blue blood of UCLA
out here losing an ax buzzer beater to
USC they're both in the other receiving
vote column right now with just single
digits what do you got for me on that
front do you think yeah I don't think
the polls mean anything so you can you
can be just outside the top 25 and
people thinking hey man they're trending
up to be one of the better teams but
your overall resume is very good like
UCLA's metrics aren't great and we've
had teams in the past that have you know
done well in the pac-12 you know
Washington when learners are Omar was
there they won the pac-12 one year
didn't get in when they didn't win the
tournament and I think we could see a
similar thing with you a UCLA if they
don't if they don't perform well in the
pac-12 tournament that they've got a ton
of losses and I think they've lost 12
maybe 13 games they've won 18 or 19 mm
but I mean they lobster just made the
tournament which is one of their losses
and and they lost a Cal State Fullerton
North Carolina beat oh and they've lost
uh some of the some of the teams you
know but most of their losses within the
conference they've been pretty good so I
think they're in decent shape but I
wouldn't feel comfortable I think they
should I think they should win a game or
two in the in the pac-12 tournament they
can get they get pushed out a few more
minutes left with Jay Bilas from ESPN
here on the Rich Eisen show I'd love to
get your thoughts on what happened to
John Beilein with the Cavs and if you
think that there's any cautionary tale
in there or this is just an outlier of a
top-notch big-time college coach going
to the NBA and it being just a bad fit
is there a moral to this story otherwise
do you think well that's a good question
I rich I'm not one of those that says
well college coaches need to serve as an
assistant the NBA they don't know the
league and all that stuff like you know
Brad Stevens and Billy Donovan gone
League and done done just fine the
difference is they went to good teams
that had a chance that had good players
had a chance to win and you know I can
give you a long list of guys
solely NBA experience that have been
miserable failures in the league because
they take bad jobs and John
took a bad job and and one where it was
going to take a long time to turn around
I can tell you I don't buy this business
about you know losing you know losing
tore him up and all that stuff I mean
you know hands up all those who love
loot love losing but if you took that
job without understanding that you were
gonna lose a lot then you were painfully
naive John made some mistakes one of
them pretty big one and and I don't
think handled it very well and he lost
his credibility and and so you know
whether he got burned out as a result of
it I haven't talked to him but I don't
know what he's a great guy and and I
think he's a great coach I think he if
he had taken a better job it would have
worked out for him a lot better but but
you know ifs and buts you know you know
how that goes yes but I'm hopeful that
he'll get back into coaching on the
college level I just don't know whether
he wants to retire straight out whether
he wants to move his wife again you know
what he wants to do going forward
haven't talked to him night and then the
last one for you would you make her
Archie Miller's comments about Sesame
Street and bracketology and all that
business which is in Lunardi what you
making that one yeah I don't know I
don't know how you feel about this but
I'm one of those that says no we in in
sports media we get to say whatever we
want and I think the coaches and the
players have the exact same right so
come after us and say whether you think
we're good or bad you know go at it but
when you do you gotta you gotta live
with how people are gonna are gonna
process it and I like Archie Miller he's
I think he's a good guy but I thought he
looked rather silly doing that like
bracketology is is entertainment like
you know Joe Lunardi and Jerry palm and
all these guys that do that it's
entertaining and and you know they don't
have any say in what the committee does
and they don't have any say and who wins
or loses games just like if I say hey I
Michigan's the best team at the bay in
in the Big Ten I think they're gonna win
the Big Ten Tournament I don't but if I
said that well that's not going to stop
Michigan State in Minnesota and Ohio
State from from winning their games so I
thought he looked like a he looked
foolish and in in doing that and
and I thought I thought he looked like
he was trying to you know if aid the
fact that his team's not very good right
now and you know our G's usually a
stand-up guy was really surprised by
that them I will call Joe is a man sorry
about that NZ said up Jose fine I've
interacted with him by email he's not
worried about it he's still in his
bunker but he doesn't need anybody's
help
but I thought Archie looked kind of
silly I think he's in his Street though
right
not his bunker he's on his in his trash
can in the street so what it sounds like
to me that that runs a stand but I was
wondering if it's Sesame Street what
does that make me am I like the count or
am I my Big Bird's or Ernie or Bert yeah
I think your big bird I'm guys smiling
I'm the game show that's the way I'm
gonna go well I was hoping it would take
me more toward the Muppets and I could
be one of those guys up in the balcony
by the way I would love to be Stadler to
your world officer any day of the week
that'd be great
yes for sure I asking the question
before he goes Chris you just love doing
ideas my favorite part J so we have a
running bit here the last week or so
about Rich's uber rating it's terrible
it's a 4/5 for do you know you are uber
rating oh yeah I'm uh I'm a five I get
because I I not only tip them on the app
like your cash afterwards I'm a double
dipper because well first of all I get a
lot of sob stories from from uber
drivers but right I can't believe how
cheap I just can't believe how cheap
that is like there are two things I tip
above what I should or at least what
what what seems to be required and that
is uber and door - like to have somebody
bring something yeah to my door right
and walk away with five bucks I think is
obscene so I I tip on on the app and
then I tip I sit in person alright Jay
not that I don't believe you again
you're above repute but I would like a
screen grab of it
text it to me we want to see that fun I
want to see it we need receipts I'll
shoot it to me as soon as you hang up
and we'll put it on it we'll put on a
show that's that's inflated clearly
you're gonna be five oh I'm done that a
couple times you're pressing dollar
bills into somebody's hand I do that man
whatever it takes your demon system no
I'm not I I could call a car service
like you most of the time but if I'm
gonna do or I mean I'm gonna treat him
like a car service driver all right Jay
by the way I also don't leave my Taco
Bell in the back take care of yourself
Jay let's chat soon we'll chat during
the tournament hopefully ours giving yo
those tables